i'm alexander rose executive director
here at the long now foundation
uh
so i think what's really interesting
about this book and uh and and tonight's
story is is that fundamentally the story
of humanity is mobility
and then now a lot of things have
happened that have made mobility
difficult right at a new time where more
mobility is even
is required because of climate change
because of politics all kinds of things
and the person who knows the most about
that and has studied it the most
is parag khanna and he's here to talk to
us tonight thank you
all right thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much xander it is so great
to be here finally
what you are looking at
is the beginning of globalization
it doesn't look like much
but we didn't have a lot of built-up
infrastructure 100 000 years ago
this photo was taken eight years ago by
paul solopeck
and he calls this place milestone zero
it's a point in the rift valley of
ethiopia where he and his sponsors and
supporters and the scientists of
national geographic believe is
effectively the original point from
which
mankind began to migrate out of the
great african continent and colonize the
world and is the beginning of what is
known as his out of eden walk project
our ancestors didn't quite know where
they were going
but walk they did
and so began not only our species
colonization of the continents
but globalization itself
he's also the embodiment
of mankind's once and future
nomadism
we got to where we are due to our
nomadic origins
and our genetic intermingling over these
preceding millennia
accounts for the surprisingly common
ancestry that all of us share
i believe that a large-scale
resettlement of the world population
is increasingly necessary to compensate
for the dangerous misalignment
in our foundational
geographies
there are four layers of geography that
underpin human civilization
and today
they are badly out of sync
the first
is natural geography
this is the geography location and
distribution of our resources
on maps such as this
brown represents the deserts
blue represents the oceans green
represents the forest and so forth
but this layer of geography is very much
in flux due to the acceleration of
climate change
industrial agriculture and deforestation
are reducing the volume and the expanse
of the green
drought and desertification are
expanding the brown
greenhouse gas emissions are turning our
air black
drying up our rivers and polluting our
oceans
as temperatures rise our glaciers melt
future maps will have less white over
the andes the rockies the alps the
himalayas
and of course the polar ice caps as well
and as sea levels rise
they encroach upon and inundate
our coastlines so future maps will
therefore also have more blue
the second layer is the political
geography
of states and borders this is the most
arbitrary of our cartographic lenses
in 1945 the united nations had only 51
members today it has nearly 200 members
that's the result of post-world war ii
decolonization after which more than 100
new countries were born and of course
the collapse of the soviet union 30
years ago
there have never been as many sovereign
states in fact as we have today
the third layer of geography is the
functional
infrastructure that we have built
these are the intentional investments
that we have been making to connect us
to each other
these lines represent the highways and
the railways the electricity grids and
the oil and gas pipelines the seaports
and airports the fiber optic internet
cables that have blanketed much of the
world
all of our supply chains much of the
global economy and quite frankly our
civilization as we know it
has come to depend on this connectivity
and here's the map that you see least of
all this is the map of us
this is our human geography it's our
distribution across the planet
every one of us 8 billion pixels
and of course
where we are
is no accident
after millennia of nomadism
the retreat of the ice age
more than 10 000 years ago enabled
humankind to settle into more sedentary
agricultural and pastoral rhythms
we did so primarily where the climate
was amenable
the so-called climate niche
with much of the world population
clustering between 20 and 30 degrees
north latitude
and within those latitudes we planted
roots as close as possible to rivers and
estuaries
environmental factors such as droughts
and floods
political phenomena such as wars and
genocides and technological advancements
such as air conditioning and the
internet
have all played a role in shaping our
human geography the grand story of our
geographic evolution
can't be told through only one
cartographic lens rather we can only
fully appreciate
the chain reactions among
and the misalignments between
these layers of geography by
superimposing them on top of each other
generating an image as messy
and as complex as it is accurate and
revealing
and what such a layering unveils to us
is the misalignment among the geography
of resources
borders
economics and people
resources are abundant where people are
few
and resources are scarce where
populations are dense
billions of people are trapped behind
borders in increasingly uninhabitable
places
while increasingly livable geographies
are actually becoming depopulated
correcting the imbalances among and
steering our system towards a more
dynamic equilibrium should become our
common civilizational mission
it's no longer an overstatement to say
that our fundamental survival depends on
rectifying these misalignments
that's because we can no longer take
global population growth for granted
instead the human population will soon
taper
plateau
and eventually decline
much sooner than we thought it would
today's youth
gen y
gen z
gen alpha
together represent 60
of the human population
but as our children
defer from having children or have fewer
children or none at all
each generational cohort is getting
smaller and smaller
and that means
that the present generation that
dominates the world today
is also going to dominate the future
to put it in sci-fi terms the present is
the future
so now we've established our nomadic
origins
our geographic misalignments and our
demographic plateau
we may reach 9 billion people on a
planet where most people live in
uninhabitable places
so where do we go from here
to say that humanity is at a crossroads
would be something of an understatement
the scenarios that we can conjure up
range from mass extinction
to a harmonious relationship with nature
in move i developed four scenarios for
the future
and for the purposes of this book i
constructed these scenarios along the
axes of sustainability and migration
we'll start with the two low
sustainability scenarios
the new middle ages
harkens back to the eurasian world of a
thousand years ago it was a fragmented
world of local survivalism
and limited trade
a world of moats and tactical alliances
to map it on to the present
it suggests a scenario in which
technological innovation to forestall
climate change and technology transfer
to promote sustainability elsewhere are
totally and utterly insufficient
furthermore migration to livable
geographies is strictly limited
the other low sustainability scenario is
called barbarians at the gate
the romans use this expression in a very
literal sense as they fortify their
settlements in the early centuries a.d
before their collapse
here we also bring in the geopolitical
dimension of water wars and land grabs
but also mass migrations as refugees
overwhelm borders
it's a similarly chaotic scenario
but a more globalized one due to
international conflict and political or
climate refugee flows
now we have the somewhat more positive
scenarios
regional fortresses is in many ways a
continuation of the present
it's a world of regional strongholds
like north america europe russia japan
that primarily invest in their own
sustainability and self-sufficiency of
agriculture energy and industry
they reign in supply chains through
near-shoring they engage in some degree
of technology transfer to support
developing regions towards similar ends
but they continue to ward off
large-scale migration
even violently if needed
less globalization may make them feel
more secure
but it doesn't make them wealthier given
their aging demographics and their
smaller markets
the fourth and final scenario is called
northern lights
it's the most optimistic
ambitious and progressive scenario
but what would it take to get there
the pathway to northern lights
calls for a resettled human population
mostly around geographies of the
northern hemisphere
but it also suggests a fluid circulation
of people
either seasonally
or to cope with various kinds of
unpredictability
whether political or ecological
in this scenario we also pre-design
our habitats to be more circular
in the usage and recycling of water
production of energy through renewable
resources and other means
today
elements of all four of these scenarios
are visible either within certain
regions and of course at the global
scale to a greater or lesser degree
and if constructed properly the future
will in fact embody
all of these scenarios the only question
is where and to what extent
i call my approach to realigning our
geographies
programmable geography
many are familiar with how evolved
computational spatial science has become
our usage of sensors on land and sea and
space has allowed us to create not only
real-time data-rich imagery of the state
of the planet's ecosystems
but also to produce sophisticated models
and use machine learning to adapt our
forecasts as new data sets are
integrated
we can not only bring our four layers of
geography together but we can map out
how these variables interact with and
shape each other
and these tools have wide-ranging
applications
we can visualize not only the present
distribution of the world population to
the level where each of us is a pixel
and a moving pixel at that
but also of course the shifts in the
climate niche
of optimal human habitation so that we
can predetermine the geographies where
our species can continue to thrive
the task of programmable geography
therefore becomes to determine
on an ongoing and unfolding basis
what geographies are suitable for human
life
at any given time and to allow people to
safely and productively relocate there
and in doing so
we're not merely reacting to climate
change and other disruptions but we are
pre-designing the pathway towards a new
model that i call civilization 3.0
here i'm trying to articulate a paradigm
appropriate to today's complex world
civilization 1.0 was when we were
nomadic and agricultural
in civilization 2.0
we became sedentary and industrial
in civilization 3.0 i propose that we
become more mobile and more sustainable
we can be nomadic as needed
and self-sufficient wherever we are
the simple fact is
that the best adaptation mechanism
and the one that we are best at and have
honed
for thousands of years
is to move
and so here it is that you see the
misalignment of our geographies hit the
hardest
political geography trumps the logic
of bringing together natural geography
and human geography
borders impede us
from exercising our basic fight or
flight instinct
people are forced to stay and die
when they could just as easily move and
survive
we can't delay this discussion or agenda
any longer because even if mitigation
efforts were to succeed
our climate is not going to return to
what it was
our global ecology is a complex system
even keeping temperatures below a 2
degree celsius rise
doesn't mean that agriculture
automatically or magically regenerates
where droughts have rained
or that aquifers are replenished where
water tables have been decimated our
future climate and the microclimates
that define where we live won't snap
back to what they were in eighteen
hundred
nineteen hundred or two thousand
it follows the laws of chaos
and it will involve in new directions
one thing is for certain
the climate will not adapt to us
we will have to adapt to it
yet we know we can do it
the past several centuries have all been
erased of mass migrations
even the 19th century which historians
refer to as the age of nationalism
actually mark the onset of mass
migrations into the tens and almost the
hundreds of millions of people
for example in the 19th century just
between europe and america 60 million
europeans migrated across the atlantic
due to famine and economic hardship
the first half of the 20th century alone
witnessed a similar number of migrants
but more due to political causes such as
ethnic expulsions from europe and the
partition of the indian subcontinent
in the latter half of the 20th century
an even larger number of migrants
surfaced in their new homes this was due
to post-colonial populations coming to
europe but a far larger number
were the 60 million latinos and asians
who came to america after the 1965
immigration act
and now in the 21st century
climate migrants they span every
continent
two things we have to remember are first
migration has risen and will continue to
from the tens of millions to the
hundreds of millions and in this century
certainly into the billions the decimal
place keeps shifting to the right
second
we have a demonstrated ability to
peacefully absorb
large-scale migration
we've been doing it steadily and doing
it peacefully for centuries the most
successful societies in the world today
america canada britain australia germany
are all places that have become mass
migration societies despite the periodic
backlash that takes place
but the directions of migration in the
future won't necessarily be the same as
those of the past
in january 2020 we saw the data from
global migration and travel for the year
2019.
as it happens we reached a high point in
all of history in the cross-border
movement of people
more than 1 billion people
legally crossed borders in the year 2019
and at that time
275 million people another high point
were classified as migrants people
living outside of their country of
origin
then it all stopped
it even reset
millions of people returned home
europeans also cooled significantly on
migration given their domestic political
backlash
and now we have severe pandemic related
restrictions
we're witnessing a return
to an overlap of geography
and nationality
so today's world effectively resembles
the regional fortresses scenario
but here's the irony
which is that even significant
intra-regional migration isn't nearly
enough to compensate for the labor
shortages the aging populations that
afflict the northern hemisphere the
acute demographic demise
of the northern hemisphere would be even
more profound and pronounced than it
already is
were it not for significant inward
migration
and the indigenous populations would
shrink and will shrink even faster in
the decade ahead due to accelerating
mortality of the baby boomer generation
and of course these regional migration
patterns took place in a pre-climate
change scenario
the world's climate niche is shifting
northward
with some pockets of potential
livability in other regions but mostly
red zones that are expanding
across the heavily populated geographies
of the world such as south america
africa south asia southeast asia and
even china
if we lived in a borderless world we'd
expect to see population shift from
coastal and urban
and tropical
to inland and northern and more
dispersed
the geographies that i refer to as
climate oases would become more heavily
populated today
some of these areas have populations of
zero
or near zero
but what about in 2030
2040
or 2050
could we play geography czar
and instantly correct our misalignments
through mass resettlement of billions of
people
not practically and of course there are
valid objections
the most significant of which is the
tragedy of the commons
so the mass migrations i'm calling for
would surely mean the devastation of the
remaining suitable habitats that we
would suddenly overwhelm
then of course their political and
cultural concerns as we move we bring
instability with us
and of course even today's so-called
climate oases aren't necessarily
paradise
heat waves and forest fires are striking
alaska greenland and siberia and of
course in all such places that we call
climate oases right now there's very
very little infrastructure
two lessons emerge from this reasoning
and the objections to it
the first is that we're not talking
about one-way tickets and one-way
movement we're talking about mobility
there are few geographies that are going
to be permanently stable shangri-las
either politically or environmentally
by definition there isn't an end state
to nomadism
even if there are new seasonal patterns
the second is
that if we move and as we move we have
to do so sustainably
which is the essence of the civilization
3.0 model
so what are the tenets or principles
that we should follow in pursuit of
civilization 3.0
let me spell out the moral the
technological and the demographic
exigencies
morally my position is what i call
cosmopolitan utilitarianism it is
cosmopolitan in that it holds all people
equal
and it's utilitarian in that it strives
for maximizing collective welfare
we don't live in a world where migration
is as fundamental a right as freedom of
speech or due process
but we should
since migration is by far the best way
to ensure that people actually can
attain these rights
among many other benefits
now let's talk about the suite of
technologies that make civilization 3.0
possible the first is what i call mobile
real estate
many millennials and gen z are opting
for mobile homes instead
they're cheaper
you can avoid environmental hazards and
you can just drive to where the work is
our survival instinct is kicking in in
addition to mobile real estate
we're also advancing in the area of what
google's astro teller calls mobile
infrastructure
even movable cities
first they're subtle communities with a
very light footprint we're investing in
the technologies to nourish ourselves
without destabilizing the environment
the dutch for example have a national
circular strategy and towns that collect
rain water and do wastewater treatment
and recycling they have solar power and
hydro and aquaponic agriculture
okay small and mobile villages that
sounds good for millions of people
what about for hundreds of millions of
people
what about places like cairo
cairo faces insufficient nile river
water while alexandria faces a rising
mediterranean sea
the people of alexandria and cairo need
desalination and they need more
efficient crop irrigation
but beware of spending billions of
dollars
on irrigation to sustain agriculture in
places where the water supply is at risk
and the delicate range of air
temperature that's right for growing
food
ultimately many people in egypt will
have to relocate
skyscrapers could well become the
stranded assets and detritus of our
present civilization
like the pyramids of ancient egypt
or they may become air-conditioned
shelters part of an archipelago of
mixed-use facilities all within a domed
city
which is exactly what's being planned
for parts of dubai
if we stay where we are
we are at best a survival society
instead we should move and we should
build a new
some models for how we could establish
sustainable and even mobile settlements
for hundreds of millions of people are
already out there
this is zatar refugee camp in jordan
what began as a temporary tent village
for iraqi refugees has become one of
jordan's largest cities
it has a permanent population of 100 000
people
there's bicycle and car sharing there's
wi-fi delivered through mesh networks
there's 3d printing and additive
manufacturing facilities and stations
there are even career development and
job training sites in placement centers
or there's the model of pop-up cities
represented by india's kumela festival
which architect rahul merotra calls an
ephemeral mega city
made of bamboo plastics light metals and
fabrics that are easily assembled and
disassembled for millions of people at a
time
there are plans to build entire sporting
arenas for future world cup soccer
tournaments in ways that will allow them
to be dismantled and relocated
rather than sitting empty for decades
for the most part building for
civilization 3.0 should be an exercise
in adaptive architecture and mobile real
estate
it's an opportunity to embrace what john
c lee brown calls
for us to be homo favor
man who makes
and to train ourselves to that end
and then of course there's the digital
technologies related to identity
citizenship and residency
for better or worse your financial
records your travel history and
itinerary your criminal records your
professional credentials are all known
and in exchange for having them accessed
responsibly as needed
we could attain a far higher efficiency
in international mobility
and who needs this mobility the most
youth
when you're talking about the future you
have to focus on today's youth
50 of the world population is under the
age of thirty ninety percent of them are
in developing countries
we are not an endless swarm of people
more like a finite swirl
we shouldn't devote energy to erecting
walls or capsizing the boats and vessels
of migrants instead we should embrace
and welcome them in the name of
preserving those who are left in our
species
solidarity can emerge without the cost
of people's identity
the study of geography and all of its
layers together
bundles the signals of our civilization
and its interactions with the planet
it channels messages from the ground
beneath our feet but also from the sky
above and it feeds those signals back to
us
and it's telling us something
it's telling us that we need to evolve
that we need to evolve from sovereignty
to stewardship
and from authority
to responsibility
that administration of geography
carries obligations to maintain and to
conserve it
our challenge boils down to this
there are 8 billion of us
and 150 million square kilometers of
terrain
how should we distribute ourselves
to maximize our collective survival
we are humans
humans in search of the right
combination
of latitude
altitude and attitude
we can be nomadic again
we can move people to resources and
technologies to people
we're in a terrible situation that's
getting worse
but we're developing the tools to build
a better future
recall that paul salope is in china
right now and heading towards russia
about 30 000 years ago
eastern eurasia was the juncture
of genetic collisions that have made us
the mongrel species that we are today
eurasia is home to two-thirds of the
world population
about 3.5 billion people
belong to the indo-eurasian language
group
what if
as we recirculate
in search of the right latitude
altitude and attitude
we enjoy another round of ethnic
intermingling that enriches our gene
pool
producing a new civilizational energy
that civilization 3.0
diverse
sustainable and resilient
is within reach
if we embrace mobility
mobility is not only our path to
survival
but to move is to rediscover what it
means to be human
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you so much
i'd love to hear a little bit more about
the this movable infrastructure idea i
think um
actually stuart and i both are houseboat
people uh i grew up on house boats and
he still lives on one um there you go
that's movable it is movable but the
irony is also that one of the things
that we found in houseboats is that once
people get their slip they don't ever
they will fight you to the death if they
have to move their boat which is always
to me seems
interesting so there's there always
seems to be this kind of nimbyism
that's that's been against the mobility
um it sounds like there's a generational
shift here but i wonder if you talked a
little bit more about various types of
movable infrastructure so there's a
couple of things there the nimbyism and
then the movable infrastructure in terms
of the nimism it's because you believe
that you are at the end of the rainbow
right that you know you have you are in
the promised land and you don't want it
to be overcrowded and obviously you have
your like-minded community
and that kind of thing and you don't
want to see a
degradation of your property values due
to various factors that may accompany an
influx of people and you know various
inequalities that may emerge and that
kind of thing but with movable
infrastructure it's really about in a
way chasing oregon as i say
pre-designing
in habitats that we know are going to be
secure or in a way to be mobile in the
instance that as i mentioned
you need to
avoid you know freak typhoon storms look
at hurricane ida it struck the gulf
coast at louisiana it flooded basements
in new jersey
what climate model told us that
hurricane ida was going to flood
basements in new jersey there are a lot
of people right now with buyers remorse
about the homes that they bought in new
jersey because of a storm in the gulf
and that's 2021. what about 20 30 once
ender right so i think we need to think
in terms of mobile infrastructure you
know uh elon musk is a great example
because he's the world's richest man
with 220 billion dollars and lives in a
50 000 boxable flat-packed home and what
we're seeing and this is definitely not
just a cottage industry right these are
mega deca corns or whatever you call
them these companies that um
are rolling off the assembly lines these
uh these you know 3d printed homes homes
that can be put on the back of a truck
and moved around that are perfectly
comfortable accommodation for families
in stable geographies uh you know there
are there are companies that are
literally just giant industrial sized
printers printing a row of homes in a
single day they're doing a lot of this
in mexico we're doing it here in the
united states so all of those are
examples of mobile infrastructures and
you know even if none of us
here
in california although of course this is
a false statement because we know that
that our geography is at risk here in
california but even if across the rich
world we manage to have stable you know
climate when you're focused on the
overall welfare of eight billion people
you know at least six billion of whom
live in developing countries at least
four billion of whom are in climate
stressed areas right now
even if everything's fine right here you
need to be thinking about mobile
infrastructure for at least half of
humanity but in fact a lot more than
half
yeah and the the history of
of
coastal civilization so far
has been that we were more willing to
build levees and walls and flood
barriers than give up the most expensive
real estate on the planet you think
that's just going to be overwhelmed or
it's just going to be a generational
shift that takes takes it away well so
there's no question that there's a set
of forces conspiring to disincentivize
young people to simply adopt that
mentality right and the first is
obviously climate change right so you
don't want to actually own that
you know terrain that coastal area
that's going to be destroyed then
you're seeing that older people don't
necessarily want to pass down that asset
right i mean real estate is supposed to
be an intergenerational transfer an
appreciating asset if you buy something
that you are going to then pass on your
children and hope that your
grandchildren will inherit that will be
worth zero potentially while you're
still alive you're going to have second
thoughts about where to buy it
and even if you don't have those
scruples guess what the insurance
industry does and that's what the
headlines from literally last week said
they said you may not care about your
flood risk but your insurance company
does flood risk flood insurance is going
to increase in price 20-fold 30-fold in
just the next few years so you really do
have to care
and then um it's young people's
preference for debt avoidance which is a
critical part of what's motivated this
whole movement towards trailer homes and
this kind of thing so not wanting to
there was a survey that i saw that cnbc
or others had conducted showing that
even among those millennials that have
bought homes which is of course fewer as
a percentage of the generation than than
than uh
than gen x or baby boomers
even amongst those that did buy homes
two-thirds have buyer's remorse for a
variety of reasons because mortgage
rates went up because they
underestimated the cost of maintenance
and these kinds of things
the demographic question that arises for
me from your charts
is you have the leveling and then
declining of human population
starting in the global north and moving
steadily in the global south
that means the the famous you know
population pyramids
with lots of people young people the
bottom and not very many old people at
the top are going
vertical
and you make all the points about the
young people are comfortable moving and
good at moving and uh
and the jobs are somewhere they're not
where they live
old people hate
people moving in on them
they hate moving i like it here or i'm
really good at being here and i would be
terrible at being anywhere else
and the global north and the global
south
the global aging and the global young
may have a generational conflict out of
this that
um
makes mobility south to north
war
and that was one of your scenarios i
know
and it's a period of time
if prosperity keeps growing
which then leads to the demographic
transition of your children typically
and so on a good question will be
uh if people plan to move do they have
large families
do they you want to take seven people
with you to canada or maximum two or
maybe less
and you know how are the demo how's the
burst rate reflecting
how people feel about the future so in
russia people are not so
excited about the future
and they're having fewer and fewer
kids
and then in japan there's fewer and
fewer kids because they've all retired
basically
and the more old people you have the
fewer young reproductive people you have
so the
demographics are so strong in relation
to
the things you're talking about with
climate
it looks like it's headed toward more
conflict rather than more resolution
so
how does that play for you i think this
is fascinating so the potential vectors
of conflict that you're describing are
both political and generational as well
as environmental yes so the
environmental one is obvious right if we
are in the low sustainability scenarios
then there will be conflict over water
food and other resources and that will
occur in multiple parts of the world
that's just understood and it has
nothing to do with generations per se
but maybe we focus on the social uh
lines of inquiry that you're asking that
are generational and national now here
are some interesting facts
all of the countries where we have seen
the political backlash against migration
right think about brexit think about
trump think about the far-right parties
in germany think about our general
sort of image of japan as an insular
anti-foreign country
all of these countries are actually
relative to their recent past mass
migration countries right
canada again is on an aggressive
campaign
to increase its population by one
percent a year that's 400 000 people per
year pound for pound there isn't a more
generous country for migration anywhere
then canada of course they have the
space for it but it's also part of their
economic strategy of diversification you
can't have a thriving services economy
with the same stock of aging people
brexit it's easier to migrate to the
united kingdom right now than it was
before brexit because they've
experienced the humiliation and the pain
of labor shortages right now there's a
shortage of 100 000 truckers their
excess mortality from not having enough
nurses was horrendous in england and in
america
so had we had smart migration policy
around certain skills and for those who
don't know it is really important to
emphasize american embassies and
consulates were open all over the world
during the pandemic do you know what
they were doing they were begging people
to fly to america who had any nursing or
healthcare experience
do you know that because i hope you know
that because it's true right so that
under the same president said we don't
want them our country's full
right our embassies were directed to
bribe anyone
away from their country where they were
taking care of their own people
to come here and take care of our people
and in germany today who would have
thought in the 1990s that in the year
2021
germany would have one million africans
five or six million turks a couple of
million arabs three or four hundred
thousand chinese people
countless slavic and you know russian
peoples and on and on and that's welcome
to germany the country that just elected
a leftish coalition and threw out the
far-right parties
and japan there have never been three
million non-japanese people living in
the islands of japan obviously that is
true today three million
now it's a drop in the bucket
but surveys of japanese people that have
been done quite regularly and recently
so the japanese as much as it's alien to
them literally
they are more or less okay with it is
what they seem to be saying you know
it's weird but it's a novelty but it's
kind of necessary we get it we need it
and all of the efforts around promoting
fertility have failed
and the countries that are doing
migration right are the countries with
fast growing economies or at least with
robust labor markets where full-time
jobs are being created that are
desirable destinations like canada and
germany so the reality of the situation
does betray the notion that we are
locked into a hostile intergenerational
my land this is my land not your land
kind of dynamic which is good news and
even in democratic liberal open
societies
as you point out though you know
basically all four scenarios are here
they're just not evenly distributed yet
as the saying goes um and in some ways
we're kind of racing them against each
other but it doesn't seem like it's
really an even playing field for how
that how victories might be judged and
how failures might be judged right so i
think that
the really interesting question and we
talked about this a little bit before is
this strong cities hypothesis um which i
think
the cities are going to be the ones that
i think will judge
kind of be judged as the winners and the
losers and that's going to be the way
that some of these millennials and
younger move
do you think that's potentially a good
force and how that might work i think
there's two important points here one is
that neo-medievalism one of the
scenarios again is in any case
irrespective of climate change one of
the emergent trends because of just the
broader devolution of authority that's
underway what's happened over time is
that you know how did central
governments
become the ruling forces that they are
through information asymmetries and
power asymmetries and today you've
eliminated information asymmetries in
fact you have this fiscal federalism and
evolution where provinces and cities are
saying wait a minute i know exactly what
happens to every dollar that i collect
or that is spent here and i want to keep
it and i don't want to send it to
washington or to whatever the case may
be so you have this fiscal and political
federalism that's become a trend around
the world within that it's cities of
course that are the winners historically
for 7 000 years cities have been the
winners we've been urbanizing right
never before have such a large
percentage of the human population lived
in cities
so the city will always win and the
question is which cities so when i point
to canada or i point to russia or i
point to japan in japan it's fukuoka
right because their urban policies
attract young people into the tech
startups and that's where you go on is
when you want to see the youthful vibe
and they're going to be parts of eastern
russia where you're going to have the
young indians and chinese and koreans
and vietnamese working as farmers and on
infrastructure projects and building the
future
you know um
industrial archipelago
of this thriving agricultural and you
know sort of uh you know sort of trade
region of siberia right so places that
no one here has necessarily heard of but
i actually profile them in the book and
i think they're very livable they're
lovely places actually um and then it's
going to be scandinavian towns it's
going to be you know calgary or uh you
know churchill canada these kinds of
places
that you know i call it actually the new
hanseatic league which is within the new
middle ages you know uh if you love
medieval history the way i do you're
throughout the honda unziotically the
alliance of trading nations of the north
sea trading states city-states and i
imagine a kind of archipelago of these
cities that say you know what i don't
know what government's in charge over
there that far-off capital right now but
i know what's good for my business i
know how to attract talent i know what
trade corridors i want for shipping and
for energy and for talent flows and
place based visas and airline routes and
i'm gonna do them
and i can definitely name you the 10 20
cities that are smart enough to do that
right now you know you look at scotland
for an example of that you know iceland
again you know cities in canada and so
forth so there are enough places doing
the right things today again the future
is here not evenly distributed but then
the north stars if you will are very
very present today this is not science
fiction
right
um but what was interesting was and the
way you described the uh the talk it was
always kind of talking from a western
perspective of
uh the attraction essentially of open
societies and democracies despite all
our kind of
dysfunction right now but you rarely
mention china and i would just love you
to overlay china into this story because
how do they fit in this in terms of an
attractor in terms of migrating a
billion point four
people i mean
you you had very little to say in that
and so many people are obsessed with the
kind of the the
the colossus of china in the in the in
the future here and i'd love you to hear
what is what is where how do you see
them going that's a great question so a
couple of things first is that you know
china also just had a census by the way
our recent census revealed that america
became more latino more diverse more
mixed race right under trump's nose you
know fyi
china census gave us a different data
point which is beyond fascinating
we had we have overestimated china's
population they overestimated their own
population but i guess how much anyone
want to take yes how much were they off
by
off how much were they off
give me a number 1.4 billion people
right
you're very close yep did you see that
in the news you're cheating
120 million people all along we thought
that china has 120 million more people
than it actually has now it still has a
lot of people right
but but what's so interesting is of
course the the demographic structure
right it's the it's the 4-2-1 pyramid
right one child caring for two parents
and four grandparents and that's the
dilemma that they're in right now and
now they've said okay definitely the one
child policy is over
please have two children actually please
have three children
not happening will never happen it's not
happening in any country even you know
france and sweden with all the benefits
barely making a dent in their fertility
and so what if they did they're tiny
tiny countries anyway so we're not going
to replenish the world population on the
back of china's attempt at a three-child
policy and chinese don't want to do it
either
uh i don't want to essentialize but you
know i mean east asia like elsewhere has
become quite materialistic you know
young people are more concerned with
their economic livelihoods and they're
very concerned about just paying the
rent right not um you know serving the
national mission to procreate and have
more children right um and this is this
is a big political issue already in
china right now
so they're going to go through a pretty
steep population decline there's no
doubt about it but they'll still be very
very large because one thing you have to
remember because we very often talk
about aging societies china is getting
old before it grows rich and so forth
china is rich first of all it's
phenomenally rich it has more than
enough money to dole out
pension payments if it wants to and to
do mobile healthcare and telemedicine if
it wants to it's doing all that stuff so
don't worry about the aging chinese
remember this
that the definition of the word median
said half the population falls below
that age china still has 700 million
young people
so it has enough money and means and
tools and resources to care for its
elderly who in any case of course will
experience gradual mortality but it has
700 million young industrious people too
it has more young people than all of
europe has people so we should not be
writing china off as if it's all aging
and dying overnight not at all right
that's that's a really important thing
and chinese people want to stay in china
which is also part of your question now
we china today
has the largest diaspora in the world 50
million people mostly concentrated in
asia mostly in southeast asia of course
one of the things i didn't get to talk
about but is is actually forms a pretty
you know big section of the book is
looking at other asian populations and
their diasporas because the median age
in china is way higher than the median
age in the rest of asia right china's
median age is like approximately like
out getting more towards our median age
whereas if you look at india in
southeast asia the median age is like 30
31.
so the vast majority of the world's
young people
are non-chinese asians but also
including chinese asians right
in fact i would go so far as to say that
kind of in a way the future of humanity
is two words asian youth
and where asian youth go more or less
determines the winners and the losers in
which cities and countries are the
winners because if you're not attracting
young industrious asians who are going
to build your infrastructure and pay
taxes take care of the old people like
filipino nurses right well your
country's gonna fall apart and no one's
gonna collect the trash or anything
right so what i foresee is a lot more
asians because of climate change again
so asians are young and dynamic and
industrious but oops they're in
climate-stressed areas
so what i'm forecasting is that the
south asian diasporas particularly the
indian diaspora but if you take all of
south asia pakistan india bangladesh
that's like 1.8 billion people
right
so the diaspora of the brown
you you know it very well here in san
francisco in silicon valley
uh will in in by the numbers become much
larger than the chinese diaspora i mean
there's no doubt in my mind that one of
the biggest demographic stories of the
next 20 years that i don't know why no
one's written about
is that the indian diaspora the south
asian aspect will be way bigger than the
chinese diaspora in the next 20 years
like millions bigger and in areas like
western europe in particular and of
course north america you will have south
asian populations significantly
outnumber chinese populations already
today actually it's not even a
prediction in the oecd world in oecd
countries
indian professionals so looking only
strictly this is oec data about
professional workforce right indi
there's already more than one million
more indians in the workforce than
chinese and while chinese are going home
indians are get me out of here right
look at my family story right um
and that'll continue to be the case and
so the ideas are our english speaking so
it's so many factors so it's it's uh
first of all
english speaking post-colonial society
right um studying math i.t healthcare
exactly the stuff we need where our
labor shortages are and i'm going to be
canada about this
not chinese
because we have a geopolitical problem
here right the fact is that i don't know
you know it's not my opinion it's not
because of i said so that the fbi is
going investigating every chinese person
who studies physics in this country
right i wouldn't want that but that's
what's happening right that doesn't
happen indians right and look at the
geopolitical alignments so it's just a
fact that the geopolitics plays a
significant role the geopolitics
trickles in the identity politics
trickles into the immigration policy and
the domestic kind of environment so
indians can go everywhere today and i
have a chapter of the book about
witnessing this in germany i i happen to
have gone to high school in germany for
for part of my time
uh for for uh as an exchange student and
believe me there were no other ethnic
indian people within a very significant
radius
today you go to germany there's indians
everywhere and there's indian restaurant
every block and the same goes for
vietnamese and every other asian ethnic
group so you're seeing it in a very
short amount of time
right
up here
hey
yeah uh so my question is about kind of
the cost of infrastructure and how that
compares like so far i think we've seen
a lot of migration that's economic like
indians moving to
the middle east it's not exactly like a
great climate choice right right it's
economic and if we're thinking about
climate migration to like siberia like
canada russia i wonder like what would
it seems to me that the infrastructure
cost of building new infrastructure
is a lot more than it would be to just
build i guess
desalination you know dykes you know
reflective paint better air conditioning
where they've already had that
infrastructure built for like 100 years
yeah and where they already live and
where they may also have a preference of
living
if the economic conditions are allowed
so we should do all of those things but
just because you may do
high albedo surfacing you know in a city
in india it doesn't prevent you from
having a zero day water event right in
the last couple of years
sao paulo
dakar senegal cape town south africa
chennai india all had zero day water
events right so what do you mean by this
so they ran out of water like literally
like you know in chennai india they had
to redirect the trains to carry water
tanks georgia had some of this even yeah
so you know there so you can't
uh reflect sunlight your way out of you
know uh um uh your your disappearing
water table right people have to move
and and one of the interesting things is
that
the largest movement of people again
during the pandemic was south asians
going home from the gulf countries right
to india and pakistan but that doesn't
mean that either a they'll never go back
to build those air-conditioned cities
that the gulf countries want to build
because they don't see themselves
leaving right and they can afford to
build their way out of it and if they
want to live in domes forever so be it
right um although they can come out in
the winter time
but the
the sort of poor you know employment the
labor migrants the construction workers
and the farmers from india
will could go to new destinations that
are now becoming the bread baskets of
the world specifically russia and
kazakhstan so we were on holiday my
parents are here by the way
so
we were on holiday in kazakhstan and
uzbekistan a couple of summers ago
because those like my favorite countries
in the world so i've been like 20 times
so we're i could not believe 20 years
i've been going to kazakhstan uzbekistan
i've never seen so many indians like
everywhere we went
the hotel cook the tour guides you've
got dentists school teachers every time
an international school opens up in a
random country because expats and
migrants have come in and they're
becoming more modern society they want
to have schools that teach in english
where do they get their english teachers
from so for a million zillion reasons
you just have this growing so they'll
find new places to go and russia is
actively china is recruiting um indian
farmers they actually tried for a while
to get south african farmers and now
they're getting indian farmers and and
so forth so you know people find a way
into these places
well it can be a climate push it can be
a political push there can be push and
pull operating at exactly the same time
stuart do you have any closing thoughts
um yeah before you wrap up xander i want
to
say two things about barack's books one
is
if you look at the back cover of move
you'll see a blurb by me
i'm enthusiastic about
the spoken about prague
and also an especially an earlier book
he does he did called connectography
it is the best book about global
infrastructure by miles
and um
demographics are destiny i think you're
right that infrastructure is the real
life
of
the global civilization that we're
finding ourselves increasingly aware
that we're in the thick of
and um
it's infrastructure in all its forms
and it is he's got a lot of ground truth
because he's traveled to these places
he's got the statistics mastered the
kinds of maps you see here that show
where things are and what goes through
them and what the traffic is is all in
there in in great detail
and
you know i'm sort of in love with
infrastructure anyway
and this is the world of it
thank you so i want to thank you so much
thank you uh for this talk he's
fantastic and perfect
you traveled you traveled both ways
around the world to get here um so thank
you
[Music]
you